my day starts with why  where i come from well i'm not connected  to one place but my connection to all  places is wherever i go i keep asking  questions you know as a little boy i was  the one getting on the nerves the  teachers my parents and my friends by  asking why why why this little boy is  now a journalist and keeps doing one  thing asking questions  my work takes me every day to the arab  region i see a lot of potential and  energy in the younger generation they  raise their voice for issues they care  for but is anyone listening  why aren't they part of the political  decisions why can't they be who they  want to be and why are they not able to  speak freely about everything they care  for  that's why i want to give the younger  generation a platform to express  themselves freely be who they want to be  and raise their questions my name is  jafar abdul karim and i work at dw